the minimum wage is increasing in 2023  in 23 States and 41 cities the pay raise  is vary Washington is on track to have  the highest minimum wage in the United  States this year at  15.74 cents an hour a number of other  states and municipalities getting to  this 15 or even higher per hour uh level  now I want to go directly to one of the  dumbest and most prevalent anti-minimum  wage increase talking points that I hear  mostly from right Wingers well David if  sixteen dollars an hour is better than  14 and 18 is better than 16 what about a  200 minimum wage  come on guys that's not that's not a  serious comment okay  a two hundred dollar minimum wage is not  an equilibrium wage either by looking at  inflation or productivity or cost of  living